ladies and gentlemen we welcome the
President of the United States and in
the very way of the United States after
less than a month in the job US
President Donald Trump returned to the
kind of rally that swept him to power
back among his adoring fans he countered
reports of turmoil within his
administration saying he was making
incredible progress in making America
great again you've seen what we've
accomplished at a very short period of
time the White House is running so
smoothly so smoothly and believe me I
and we inherited one big mess that I can
tell you and of course he didn't miss an
opportunity to take a swipe at the media
when the media lies to people I will
never ever let them get away with it I
will do whatever I can that they don't
get away with it they have their own
agenda and their agenda is not your
agenda along with the familiar messages
there was also an element of surprise
when he invited an admirer up on stage
this guy a declaration of love that
illustrates that for many of his
supporters president Trump is delivering
on their expectations